>> INSANE VIDEOS THAT CAPTURES
AMERICA'S FENTANYL CRISIS.
A FLORIDA POLICE OFFICER ALMOST
DYING AFTER SHE GOT EXPOSED TO
THE DEADLY DRUG DURING A TRAFFIC
STOP.
>> DID YOU GET A WARRANT?
>> 47.
SHE IZZO DIENG -- IZZO DIENG.
>> SHE IS BELIEVED TO HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO THE LETHAL OPIOID.
SHE WAS QUICKLY GIVEN TWO DOZES
OF NARCAN AND EVERYTHING SEEMED
OKAY.
THEN THIS HAPPENED.
WATCH.
>> BREATHE.
>> COME ON, BREATHE.
HIT HER AGAIN.
SHE IS NOT BREATHING.
>> AFTER A THIRD DOSE OF NARCAN
AN ABSENCE BROUGHT HER TO THE
HOSPITAL WHERE SHE IS EXPECTED
TO MAKE A FULL RECOVERY.
OF ALL THE THINGS PLEASE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH, PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
THESE TRAFFIC CARS WITH GUNS,
EVERYTHING NARCAN NOW YOU GOT TO
WATCH OUT FOR.
>> Jeanine: THAT WAS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WERE STARTING TO
DO WITH FENTANYL.
I WAS ABLE TO GET NARCAN WHEN I
WAS EDA.
THERE WERE OVER 43 POLICE
OFFICERS -- COULD YOU GIVE US
MONEY FOR NARCAN?
SO THAT WE GAVE IT TO POLICE
OFFICERS AND POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
I TELL YOU THAT IS ONE OF THE
FEW TIMES YOU WILL SEE THIS BUT
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME ACROSS
AMERICA.
THERE IS NO WAY TO EVENT WHETHER
OR NOT THERE IS FENTANYL IN A
CAR, IN A DOLLAR BILL, OR IN A
CASE OR WHATEVER POLICE ARE
GOING.
SHE IS LUCKY THAT THERE WAS
SOMEONE ELSE ON THE SCENE WHO
WOULD GIVE THE NARCAN AND
UNDERSTOOD WHAT IS GOING ON.
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR THIS TO ME
IS WE HAVE GOT TO WIPE OUT IN
CHINA THOSE BATTERIES THAT ARE
CREATING THE FENTANYL WITH THIS
BEING SENT THROUGH -- TO THE
CARTELS.
THEY ARE KILLING US AND WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
JOE BIDEN OF COURSE HAS OTHER
PRIORITIES.
BUT IF WE HAD A STRONG PRESIDENT
AND IF WE HAD SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTOOD THAT 300 PEOPLE A DAY
ARE DYING FROM THIS, 300
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE, THEN THEY
WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE
GOT A LITERALLY WIPED OUT THOSE
FACTORIES IN CHINA.
AND STOP SAYING CHINA, YOU KNOW,
IT IS A GOOD COUNTRY.
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD INVITE
THIS OFFICER TO THE WHITE HOUSE
AND TALK TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DIRECTLY ABOUT THIS.
>> I THINK THAT IS A GREAT IDEA.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE A
PARTISAN SCUFFLE ON THIS.
I WOULD PUSH BACK ON THE IDEA
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
ADDRESSED IT AT ALL.
HE GAVE ABILITY TO HAVE DOLLARS
TO EVERY SINGLE STATE TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS.
42.5 MILLION.
AND LET YOU SPEAK.
JUST LET ME FINISH.
AND THEN YOU CAN SAY THAT
EVERYTHING I SAID WAS, IN A,
FAIRY DUST OR WHATEVER.
>> AGREED.
>> OKAY.
SO HE IS PUSHING TO MAKE NARCAN
OVER THE COUNTER TO MAKE SURE
THAT MORE PEOPLE CAN HAVE IT.
THERE'S FEDERAL FUNDING GOING TO
BUY FENTANYL TEST STRIPS.
IF YOU ARE EXAMINING CASH, YOU
CAN USE THE TEST AHEAD OF TIME.
IT IS A HUGE PROBLEM AND IT IS A
GENERAL -- GEOPOLITICAL PROBLEM
AND I BELIEVE HE IS TRYING HIS
BEST IN TERMS OF FUNDING FOR THE
CRISES BUT OBVIOUSLY IT HAS TO
BE STAMPED OUT ON AN
INTERNATIONAL LEVEL.
>> HOW IMPORTANT IS IT TO SHOW
THIS FOOTAGE OF AN OFFICER GO
DOWN LIKE THAT AND ALMOST DIED?
>> ONE THING FOR HER PRIVACY, IT
IS NOT AVAILABLE TO HER.
SHE WAS WILLING TO LET PEOPLE
SEE THAT THIS WAS HAPPENING.
I TALKED TO CHIEF BILLY HOFFMAN.
HE SAID IT IS PROBABLY SOMEHOW
PLACED IN COCAINE OR HEROIN THAT
WAS BEING TRAFFIC.
SO --
>> Jeanine: FENTANYL.
>> SHE IS DOING THE RIGHT THING
DOING HER JOB AND SHE GETS INTO
A POSITION WHERE SHE ALMOST
LOSES HER LIFE.
HE SAID ALL OF HIS GUYS CARRY
MULTIPLE DOSES OF NARCAN.
WE HAVE TALKED TO PARENTS
MULTIPLE TIMES ON AMERICA'S
NEWSROOM IN WHICH THEY HAVE HAD
NARCAN IN THEIR HOMES OR CARS
WHEN THEIR TEENAGE KID GOES INTO
SOMETHING THAT YOU DON'T
RECOGNIZE.
IT IS LIKE AN OPIOID SHOCK.
YOU ALMOST NEED TO HAVE CPR
TRAINING FOR A FAMILY.
JESSICA, I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU CAN PUT MONEY TOWARDS
THIS PROBLEM.
JOE BIDEN NEVER TALKS ABOUT THE
BORDER.
WE KNOW THIS IS COMING FROM THE
BORDER AND IT IS NOT JUST
FUNCTIONAL.
WE TALKED TO A POLICE OFFICER IN
MICHIGAN THE OTHER NIGHT.
THEY HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM OF MATH
IN THE WESTERN PART OF MICHIGAN
AND HE SAID IT IS MEXICAN MATH
AND HERE AND IT IS CHEAP.
SO ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS,
THERE'S A ROOT CAUSE OF IT.
AND WE CAN THROW MONEY AT THIS
PROBLEM.
BUT UNTIL WE DEAL WITH THAT
WOULD CAUSE BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY IN THE WORLD TO
DEAL WITH IT.
APPROPRIATELY.
>> YOU CAN'T BE SERIOUS AND NOT
CRACKDOWN AND MENTION IT BUT YOU
CAN'T BE SERIOUS AND NOT MENTION
THE CHINESE LEADER.
5,000 PEOPLE OF THE WHITE HOUSE
TO CELEBRATE THE FINAL
LEGALIZATION OF INTERRACIAL
MARRIAGE.
FINALLY, BLACKS AND WHITES CAN
VARY.
I THINK WE HANDLE THAT 100 YEARS
AGO.
FOR HIM TO FOCUS ON THAT AND
NEVER BRING UP THE BORDER OR THE
INTRODUCTIONS CAN NEVER GO DOWN
THERE, GO TO A REHAB CENTER OR
GO TO A DOES HAVE A FAMILY --
BECAUSE THEY WERE TAKING RITALIN
TO STAY UP TO STUDY AND THE KID
ENDS UP DEAD.
IF YOU START DOING THOSE THINGS,
THAT IS THE MESSAGING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
FORMER PRESIDENT PUT CONLEY IN
FRONT OF IT.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN COMPARE
THE LAST TWO ADMINISTRATION'S.
CHINA COME TO US WITH THEIR
STATEMENT WHEN THEY CAME OUT AND
SAID AMERICA SHOULD NOT WORRY
ABOUT OUR UPRISINGS.
WRITE ABOUT HOW MANY FENTANYL
DEBTS IN THEIR COUNTRY.
THEY ARE MANUFACTURING THE
FENTANYL THAT IS KILLING US.
>> Jeanine: AS MUCH MONEY THIS
ADMINISTRATION CAN THROW AT THE
PARTY, UNTIL YOU CHANGE THE
POLICY, NOTHING WILL CHANGE.
UNTIL YOU GET IT AT THE HEAD,
WHICH IS THE ENTRANCE OF MEXICO,